Speaker 1: You know, usually when I say, hey,
here's what the right is saying, and here's
why it doesn't make sense because it could
happen and B could happen. A and B don't usually
happen within like a few days. But with the
entire definition of a woman thing, it has
now happened with Republican Senator Josh
Hawley. And we're going to look at it because
it's exactly why I said the idea that it's
so simple to define woman as far as Republicans
are concerned really isn't borne out by the
actual fact. So let's backtrack a little bit.
When Judge Katju Brown Jackson's confirmation
hearings were going on, Senator Marsha Blackburn,
a Republican, said, Can you define a woman?
And Judge Jackson said, You know, in the context
of legality, I really can't, because when
we figure out if the question is who can bring
a gender discrimination lawsuit, it depends
on the specific facts of a case, so I can't
really tell you. And then she went on to say,
I'm also not a biologist, so I can't give
you like a biological definition. I'm a judge.
And one of the things I said to you guys was,
it's not as simple as it seems. And within
a few days, I appeared on the right wing Michael
Knowles show, and he suggested the definition
for a woman, anyone who's not a man. And of
course, that doesn't really work. It ignores
intersex people. And then he said, Well, it's
a human that produces eggs. Well, there's
lots of conditions like hormonal imbalances
and thyroid conditions and things in the womb
and pituitary tumors, which prevent women
from producing eggs. But they're still women.
And then there was well capable of reproduction
through pregnancy. Lots of conditions inhibit
reproduction. What about post-menopausal woman?
What about a postmenopausal woman? What about
a woman who has had a hysterectomy? Well,
by his? By that definition, they wouldn't
be a woman. This brings us to Republican Senator
Josh Hawley, who was recently asked about
this. And in fact, HuffPost asked a bunch
of Republican senators, Can you define woman
in? Most of them didn't even answer, probably
because they realized, even though we pretended
it was really easy for Judge Jackson to answer.
We're not answering either. But Josh Josh
Hawley did, to his credit. And Josh Hawley
initially said someone who can give birth
to a child, a mother is a woman. Someone who
has a uterus is a woman. It doesn't seem that
complicated to me. And so the follow up was
What if a woman has her uterus removed by
a hysterectomy? Is she still a woman? And
Josh Hawley initially said, Yeah, well, I
don't know. Would they? And the answer was
yes. And later, when Josh Hawley was asked,
Well, would you consider a woman to be a woman
if she lost her reproductive organs to cancer?
Hawley said, I mean, a woman still has a vagina,
right? Which is a different definition. First,
it was capable of reproduction. Then it was
like, Well, actually, that's not the definition.
It's having a vagina. And then, of course,
there are trans women who have vaginas. He
wasn't asked about that, but the point here
is these definitions don't work in figuring
out. Who is a woman for specific purposes,
right? If the question is, who is a woman
for needing OB-GYN care? Well, there are definitely
some transwomen that don't need an OB-GYN.
But then there's a different question who
is a woman for the purposes of bringing a
gender discrimination lawsuit? And that's
a different definition. So the most important
takeaway is they want everybody else to think
there's one definition for all contexts, and
it's really simple. And anyone who doesn't
give you that definition is being dishonest
or they're being unrealistic or whatever.
And even Josh Hawley's definition that came
from him already ran into a bunch of problems
needing him to backpedal. So if we need any
reminder that it's not as simple as they make
it out to be, we now have as a data point
that Josh Hawley himself, who was on those
confirmation hearings for Judge Jackson, although
he didn't ask these particular questions.
He's already had to revise his definition.
Very interesting data point. When the people
who follow you politically. Our number one,
willing and able to be convinced of anything
you tell them, even if it's not true. And
number two, willing to do violence, you have
to be really careful when you're telling them
lies. And this is more true than ever with
the modern reactionary, right? We might call
it the neo reactionary, right. I don't know
what to call them, because again, as I've
said before, these Trumpists aren't conservative
by the traditional definitions. They weren't
even really involved in politics, many of
them until Trump came up. There really are
neo reactionary movement. And the problem
is that the people feeding them drivel and
pablum have no consideration for whether these
folks are going to hear what they say and
go and take real world violent action. And
it's already happened. It's already happened.
But we're going to talk about in a moment.
But this brings us to something that radical
Republican Congresswoman Marjorie Taylor Greene
recently said she and some others have gotten
on this idea that anybody who supports Judge
Katju Brown Jackson for the Supreme Court
is either a pedophile or is pro pedophilia.
Now you might say, Wait, but David, what?
That doesn't make any sense. You'd be right.
It doesn't make any sense. But but the way
they have spun this is. Judge Jackson has
issued sentences for all sorts of different
crimes to all sorts of different people over
many years as a judge in different on different
courts. And sometimes the sentence she gives
is not what the state asks for, what the prosecution
asks for. Sometimes it's somewhere between
what the prosecution asks for and what the
defense asks for. And as all judges do, she
weighs factors and issues a sentence. And
the fact that that happened with some examples
of individuals who had explicit images of
children, what is sometimes called child porn.
Although I don't think that's a good term
because porn typically is legal in between
involving consenting individuals, child porn
is something very different. I've already
said that sometimes her sentence has departed
from the recommendation or what the prosecutors
wanted, so they're saying she's pro pedophile
and the people supporting her might be pedophiles
themselves. Here is such an example of Marjorie
Taylor Greene saying that
Speaker 2: the Democrats are the party of
pedophiles. The Democrats are the party of
princess predators from Disney. The Democrats
are the party of teachers, elementary school
teachers trying to trying to transition their
elementary school aged children and convince
them there are different gender. This is the
party of their identity, and their identity
is the most disgusting, evil, horrible things
happening in our country. And that's why we
have to say it. We have to be willing to say
it. And no matter how many little blue check
marks get their feelings hurt on Twitter.
So, you know it's worth to.
Speaker 1: This is liable to get people killed.
Now, why is that? Well, we have a dangerous
cult here. We have a dangerous cult that refuses
to or is enabled to think critically about
the things that they're being told. We have
a cult that by a large, much larger share
than independents and Democrats believes it's
OK to use real world violence to achieve political
goals. So they believe things that aren't
true and they're willing to use violence.
And this could genuinely lead some of Marjorie
Taylor Greene's followers and other Trumpists
to go and target Democrats with guns, or even
the three Republicans who said they'd be voting
for Judge Katagiri Brown Jackson. Remember,
we looked at this on the show a couple of
days ago, Marjorie Taylor Greene tweeted.
Murkowski, Collins and Romney are pro pedophile.
They just voted for Kay B.J.. This is extraordinarily
dangerous, and we have examples of it. Remember,
there was this one story of the man who was
targeting Liberals and the Tides Foundation.
This is an old story. This is 11 years old.
I remember covering this when it happened.
Byron Williams told investigators he wanted
to start a revolution by killing people of
importance at the Tides Foundation and the
ACLU. Where did he get that idea? Well, he
got it, among others from Glenn Beck. And
he said that when California Highway Patrol
pulled him over, we did the story. We have
the Pizzagate shooter, Pizzagate gunman. This
is from 2017 sentenced to four years in prison.
This was a guy who became convinced, thanks
to what Republicans were saying at the time,
that Comet Ping Pong, a pizza shop in D.C.,
was somehow the nexus of some kind of child
sex trafficking ring involving Democrats.
And I mean, listen, I don't remember exactly
all the claims they were making, but it was
completely and totally bonkers. There was
the pipe bomber, the Trumpist pipe bomber.
I don't even remember the date it was while
Donald Trump was president, who was also shot.
This is not like maybe it'll happen someday.
We know that these types of comments from
people like Marjorie Taylor Greene are stochastic
terrorism. It's extraordinarily dangerous
and she's going to get people killed. Let
me know your thoughts. Find me on Twitter
at David Pakman and remember that Tuesday,
April 19th, we'll be doing the next David
Pakman show Town Hall. It'll be at 6:00 p.m.
Eastern Time on the Pacman Live YouTube channel.
That's youtube.com slash Pacman live. We'll
take a quick break and be right back. So there
continues to be something very wrong with
many of the reporters regularly in the White
House press briefing room just determined
to ask ridiculous questions of Jen Psaki.
And in this segment, we're going to look at
two clips. One is Steve Portnoy from CBS News
now with Steve Portnoy does is less about
Steve, and it's more about something many
reporters have been doing in corporate media
since the Russian invasion of Ukraine started.
Then we'll look at Peter Doocy, who is kind
of a different type of character in these
situations, asking different types of questions,
but they're all absurd. So first question
Steve Portnoy from CBS News ask Jen Psaki
Why is the United States not pushing for like
a real world war against Russia at this point
in time? And there seems to be, and I think
we know why, a real desire among many in corporate
media to see that happen, to see what's happening
with Russia and Ukraine boil over into a true
world war. And Jen Psaki does some good things
here, including asking specifically, what
exactly is it you would like to see? Take
a
Speaker 3: look. Why shouldn't the images
of the atrocities from bloodshed compel a
worldwide unified coalition?
Speaker 2: Kinetic response? You mean a military
war? Tell me more about what you mean for
Speaker 3: a military response led by the
United States and the
Speaker 2: international partners as in bringing
military troops on the ground from the United
States and Naito.
Speaker 3: Well, the president described outrageous
things you call the atrocities you've said.
Perhaps we should brace ourselves for worse.
Why not?
Speaker 2: I think what the president's objectives
and his responsibility is to make decisions
that are in the interests of the United States
and the national security of the United States
and the American people. And that is not to
go to war with Russia. It is to do everything
in our power to hold them accountable, to
support efforts through international systems,
to do exactly that and to provide military
assistance, security assistance and support
to the Ukrainian people and the Ukrainian
government. That's exactly what we're doing.
But it is not in our interests or in the interests
of the American people for us to be in a war
with Russia. Go ahead. So.
Speaker 1: I I don't I don't even know if
Steve Portnoy personally has this view, but
much of the corporate media has decided, probably
correctly, if you look at history, that if
there was really like a full scale war against
Russia or against Russia in Ukraine, maybe
better said that it would be great for corporate
media ratings. And it's probably true. It's
probably true. I mean, if it bleeds, it leads.
Conflict is good in general for corporate
media. And so it's not just Steve Portnoy,
that's the clip that we're looking at here.
But many in right wing media have been asking
both Joe Biden and Jen Psaki questions like
they're in corporate media have been asking
Jen Psaki and Joe Biden, were you too quick
to rule out some major escalation? Boots on
the ground, sending troops in drones, whatever.
Um, do you think that you're giving Putin?
You're emboldening Putin by actually saying
what you're not willing to do or whatever
the case may be? Do you regret not taking
a harder position and they seem to just want
the biggest possible war? They seem almost
incredulous that Joe Biden doesn't want to
do that, and I commend Joe Biden for that.
We can have a debate and it can be a hearty
debate, and it can be a good faith debate
about what would have been the right things
to do and when when it comes to Russia and
Ukraine going back, we can talk about Crimea
in 2014. That's that's fair. That's fair game.
We can talk about continued occupation of
the Donetsk and Luhansk regions of Ukraine
by Russia while Trump was president. These
are all legitimate things. But generally speaking,
Joe Biden has handled the situation pretty
well. He's provided a ton of support. Military
aid training to Ukrainian soldiers in Poland.
Drones has even sent over. So if you want
Joe Biden to help, he's done it. And if you
don't want Joe Biden to get us quote into
another war, as has become a popular talking
point on the left and right and generally
speaking, a talking point I agree with, I
don't want war. He has set a line which is
we're not getting boots on the ground, but
the corporate media seems to be desperate,
not because they care geopolitically. I don't
think Steve Portnoy and all these people have
geopolitical motivations. It's just about
what's good for corporate media. So that's
number one. I hope Biden stands completely
firm on no boots on the ground. Separately,
we have Peter Doocy and Peter Doocy asks Jen
Psaki, would Joe Biden support appointing
a special counsel to investigate his own son,
Hunter Biden? Yeah. Let's look at that clip
and then we'll talk about that
Speaker 3: on another topic. A lot of stories
about Hunter Biden surfacing this week, so
to ensure the independence of the investigation,
would the president support the appointment
of his special counsel?
Speaker 2: Well, first, the president has
never had a conversation with the Department
of Justice about any investigations into any
member of his family. He said that during
the campaign, and he will continue to abide
by that. So I point the Department of Justice
for any additional steps they would take.
They would make those decisions independently.
Speaker 3: Is there any concern that they're
not going to be necessarily seen as being
able to make the decisions independently of
the White House? Chief of staff is out saying
that the president is confident his son did
not break the law.
Speaker 2: Well, that's something the president
has said and certainly we would echo. But
in the same answer to that question, Peter,
during an interview this week on the ABC,
Ron Klain also said the Justice Department
is independent and they will make their own
decisions.
Speaker 3: And the president has said that
he never spoke to his son about his overseas
business dealings. Is that still the case?
Yes.
Speaker 1: So again, I had a conversation
here in Las Vegas earlier with Farron Cousins
from Ring of Fire, and we talked a little
about a little bit about Hunter Biden. I believe
that Joe Biden is doing the exact right thing
when it comes to Hunter Biden, and he's doing
what he promised to do. He is not getting
involved and trying to stop the investigation
into Hunter Biden's business dealings in 2018.
Presidents shouldn't on the one hand, presidents
shouldn't try to get the Justice Department
to investigate anybody in particular, and
Joe Biden is doing that, and he could. There's
plenty of people from the Trump era that Joe
Biden could be going to the Justice Department
in saying, Hey, this is something you should
really be looking at. Investigate this charge,
people. Maybe he's not doing that. That's
correct. And he's also not trying to obstruct
the investigation into Hunter Biden. That
is exactly what Joe Joe Biden should have
no involvement. And as I've said before, I
couldn't care less about Hunter Biden. If
Hunter Biden committed crimes, charge him.
If Hunter Biden is found guilty of crimes,
punish him. It just has nothing to do with
Joe Biden's administration. And there's also
a confusion happening between the investigation
into Hunter Biden and the laptop. The investigation
doesn't have anything to do with a laptop,
and a lot of people also don't seem to understand
that. Reporters just really making fools of
themselves every single day in that press
briefing room. Guys, I love this story. Mike
Pillow, Mike Lindell, the CEO of MyPillow.
He was just finishing up, giving a speech
in Colorado, and he was served with a lawsuit
on camera. This is. I love this. I relish
this. Is it schadenfreude? Schadenfreude?
Every time I say it, someone emailed me, says
David. You're pronouncing it wrong. You guys
know exactly what I'm talking about as Mike
Pillow is walking away from a speech about
election integrity in Colorado. He gets served
by Eric Koumas. Defamation lawsuit Eric Coomer
is this former employee of Dominion Voting
Systems. Pillow has been hammering on Coomer
for a while, and the best part about this
video is initially, Pillow doesn't realize
he's being served legally here, and he tries
to kind of walk away and says he doesn't want
the papers. Then he realizes he's been served
and he looks dejected and he sounds dejected.
And I love it. I really do. Take a look at
this video. Listen to the audio here.
Speaker 3: Thank you, Mike. Thank you for
everything. What is this? Oh, sure, sure.
What does this tell you? Well, what is enough
for me? It's not for me. I need you to open
up my bathroom. Oh dear, sorry.
Speaker 1: To informed. It's always nice to
have video evidence of proof of service. Sue,
all these guys, if the facts point that way.
Sue every single one of them and it's I don't
know if this is even a guilty pleasure of
mine, but you really love to see it. And I
don't know that Mike Pillow realizes the amount
of trouble that he's in. This really could
destroy him financially. He has a lot of money.
I know it really could. Sidney Powell, the
other she was, I guess she's she still is
a lawyer, even though she's been disbarred
a bunch of places. She was pushing a lot of
these bogus, frivolous legal complaints around
the 2020 election. I'm you never hear me say
sue them. I say sue them if the evidence points
to it. And it seems that the evidence points
to lawsuits against Mike Pillow and one of
the things that again, we talk about projection
the right. Generally speaking, it's the right
that says we need tort reform, which often
by tort the tort reform, they mean we need
to make it more difficult for individuals
to be able to hold corporations accountable.
You have to understand in general when they
when the right talks about tort reform, they
mean let's make it easier for corporations
to do whatever the hell they want and make
it more difficult for them to be held accountable.
They talk all the time about frivolous lawsuits,
frivolous. So this lawsuits frivolous. That
lawsuit is frivolous. Courts can determine
that courts have courts are very well-equipped,
equipped to determine whether a lawsuit should
or shouldn't move forward. And if it shouldn't,
they dismiss lawsuits? And one of the things
that was found by courts is that they were
filing the frivolous lawsuits and frivolous
legal complaints in the aftermath of the 2020
election. And if they've done it in a way
that is systematic and is a waste of the court's
time, 100 percent hold them accountable pillows
getting sued again, and he's got a big legal
bill coming and something about that. VIDEO
That video is from a Marshall Selinger with
nine news. Really good job of Salinger was
just there, and he happened to get the process
server delivering the papers. It's just fantastic.
He has got a big uphill legal battle in front
of him. And of course, he continues to claim
pillow. Does that were like days from the
evidence coming out or whatever? It's wacky.
These people are bonkers. And unfortunately,
a lot of their followers believe every word
they say. So we'll track this lawsuit. But
you really love to see that clip if you didn't.
If you're listening today and you're not watching,
you can see the delivery of the papers. We'll
have it on our Instagram at David Pakman show.
Speaker 4: It's great to welcome to the program
today. Bill von Hippel, who's a professor
of psychology at the University of Queensland
in Australia and also author of the book The
Social Leap The New Evolutionary Science of
Who We Are, Where We Came From, and What Makes
US Happy. So great to have you on today. I
really appreciate it.
Speaker 5: Thanks for having me, David.
Speaker 4: So I mean, I guess to pick somewhere
to start, there's often conversations about
when, when we're humans modern and when would
we look at past humans and say, yeah, at least
physically and generally speaking, that's
the same sort of species that that is us.
But there's maybe a little bit less time paid
in popular culture to what was humanity like
at at sort of some of those earlier stages.
So maybe we go to the kind of rainforest to
savannah phase. Talk to us a little bit about
what would be the big differences we'd notice,
I guess.
Speaker 5: Sure. So if you go back to when
we were still the same species as our cousins,
the chimpanzees. So we're talking six or seven
million years ago living in the rainforest,
all the data that we have suggests that we
would look a lot like modern chimps. Not exactly,
but awfully close. And then when we left the
rainforest and moved to the savanna and actually
it was the rainforest that left us it dry
it out in the region that we were on. But
when we left, it moved to the savanna. We
were still probably very chimp like for a
long time. And in fact, if you fast forward
the clock about three million years to australopithecines,
you could see them standing next to a chimp.
And the primary difference between them would
be that the australopithecines can stand straight
up, that they're completely bipedal, but they
they look awfully a lot like a chimp. They
are in their structure and almost everything
else about them. It doesn't look like we're
moving anything towards humanity. It's not
really until about 1.7 million years ago,
maybe two million years ago, when we get to
Homo erectus that we start to see an ancestor
who you would expect to be on your side of
the glass at the zoo rather than on the other
side.
Speaker 4: When we talk about modern humans,
it is the best science we have. Still that
that phase goes back about two hundred and
fifty thousand years.
Speaker 5: Yeah, that's that's a great number.
The downside, of course, is that there wasn't
one day where we were or weren't humans and
then were right, and so it's a very slow spread
when you look at fossils that are a little
older than that. You start to see pictures
that don't look a lot like modern humans,
but just a few. And when you look at fossils
that are younger than that, you even occasionally
see things that look a little archaic as well.
Speaker 4: There are many efforts made by
sometimes. I don't want to say modern psychology
like pejoratively, but but by some modern
psychologists, sometimes to explain certain
responses that we humans have today to certain
stimuli by telling stories about what things
would have been like when humans were on the
savanna. You know, the idea of the fight or
flight response, which we might have now in
public speaking? You often hear analogies
to, well, it's better to err on the side of
if there might be a lion coming to have sort
of that reaction. Another example is I recently
spoke to an expert on sleep paralysis and
other conditions, and we talked about the
very common dream of falling. And his idea
was that may go back to when we were in the
trees, and there would be an evolutionary
advantage to having that kind of startle response,
even when it's only a dream that you are falling
because it might, you might really be sort
of falling out of a tree. Those stories, how
useful do you think they really are in kind
of thinking about our past?
Speaker 5: I think they're useful sometimes,
but they're really primarily useful in developing
hypotheses. And so if you think, well, public
speaking, maybe that's some sort of ancient
response to two lions or saber tooth on the
savanna, something like that. Well, you need
to explore that hypothesis. Say, what does
that tell us? Now, personally, I don't think
that would get you anywhere because what was
a bigger deal to our ancestors but was no
longer saber tooth on the. But the possibility
that our group might reject us and if ever
this is a chance to in my group, reject me
all at once is when I'm publicly speaking
and in saying something to everybody. If I
say something wrong, that's a great chance
for them all to agree. All right. Time to
give Bill the heave ho, which for our ancestors
was a death sentence.
Speaker 4: That's interesting. That's interesting.
So and I think in you've written quite a bit
about how social behavior may be heavily dictated
today by our ancient ancestors and the evolutionary
pressures so that would be taking. It's the
same story that's often told. But it's really
applying more of a social interpretation to
it than a biological one, I guess.
Speaker 5: Absolutely. And then the key is
you need to find a way to try to test it.
And most of the research that we've done,
for example, and rejection, shows that our
responses are way stronger than they are to
the fear of predators and other physical stimuli.
A cliff, you might fall off something like
that.
Speaker 4: The social rejection thing Jonathan
Hite has written about this a little bit and
also including in terms of religiosity, where
in the past, if you didn't go with the predominant
beliefs of the Klan, it might increase the
odds that you get rejected. And at the time
it was much more it was less trivial to be
socially rejected, maybe than it is now in
terms of our survival. We're now, one could
argue, I don't really have to be part of a
church or I can even be a loner and at least
stay alive to a greater degree. Can you talk
a little bit about how that that rejection
risk has really changed over time?
Speaker 5: Well, the funny thing about that
rejection risk is, as you say, it hardly matters
anymore. Not only would you and I be just
fine if all of our friends decided they didn't
like us because we can still survive. But
even more importantly, we can move to a new
neighborhood and get a new set of friends.
But our ancestors didn't live like that. They
lived in groups that were relatively close,
so to speak. They broke up and regathered,
but in only within a relatively small clan.
And so they couldn't afford to risk their
reputation in the same way that you and I
can today. And this is the exact kind of evolutionary
disconnect that you were talking about earlier
in our past, it mattered a great deal. Now,
it probably doesn't matter as much, but there's
nothing more painful to people than rejection.
And there's nothing that drives us more than
people making fun of us, people doing the
kinds of things that we see our hunter gatherer
ancestors do before they reject a member,
the group, they ostracize them. They tease
them, ostracizing and teasing make us feel
terrible because those ancestors who wouldn't
respond to that are the ones who. Then they
took the next step and they gave them the
heave ho.
Speaker 4: Thinking still, along these lines,
I've heard folks like, for example, Jordan
Peterson, make the argument that the possibility
of a physical confrontation between men. That's
kind of how he would say always there in the
kind of background and socially important
is a driving factor in many ways for the advancement
of society in some way. And I say this both
as someone who I hope I'm representing accurately
what he said and I'm also not a Peterson fanboy.
I've been very critical of many things, he
said. I'm just interested in the idea that
there's this when men interact and. Society
and Western society, at least there's the
possibility that if things don't go well,
it may devolve into a physical confrontation.
Can you talk a little bit about whether that's
a conflict with what others say is the human
kind of proclivity for peaceful relations
rather than than violent relations? And see
if we can make a little bit of sense out of
that.
Speaker 5: Yeah, that's a great question.
So if you look at our chimpanzee cousins,
there are about 500 times as likely to come
into physical conflict with other members
of their group than humans are. And so when
we look at human hunter-gatherers, so there's
no police to stop, you know, government. We
see a ratio of 500 to one for every one conflict
we have, where we fight with each other over
something. They have five hundred. But if
you look at our chimpanzee cousins, when they
interact with members of other groups now
you see a one to one ratio. There exactly
is conflicted with members of other groups.
As we are, we are exactly as much as they
are. And so basically, we we've evolved to
be hyper cooperative. We work together incredibly
well. But that's primarily within our groups.
When we're looking at between group relationships,
they look a lot like chimpanzees did. And
so human males in particular are the ones
who, when the conflict comes, they tend to
get into it. But if you look at us within
our groups, although we formed shallower relationships
than human females do, on average, those shallow
relationships allow us to kind of form coalitions
that dissipate and then that reform later
without any hard feelings. But those coalitions
almost never get formed when we cross group
boundaries, and that's where we see the real
violence that's part of our nature is
Speaker 4: the explanation for this, simply
that if you work together rather than fight
with each other, everybody's more likely to
survive both as a species and as a community
and as an individual.
Speaker 5: Well, yes. And the reason that
the chimpanzees never crossed that particular
Rubicon is they never got to the point that
we got to on the savanna where there was enormous
benefit to be gained if everybody would cooperate.
And so when you look at chimpanzees psychology,
they're very clever. They do lots of things
very well, but they're fundamentally competitive
with one another. As a consequence, the individual
goals and the group goals never aligned. Whereas
once we move to the savanna, once we became
bipedal and now we could protect ourselves
from predators. Now our individual goals came
into alignment with our group goals, and as
a consequence, it benefited us individually
to cooperate, and it made us incredibly successful
as an evolutionary story.
Speaker 4: That's very interesting in thinking
back. I mean, there's some characteristics
that now seem sort of trivial. Like, for example,
I cite, you know, you're wearing glasses,
I wear contact lenses. It's not a big deal.
You know, we adjust the prescription as needed.
And we can imagine a time in the past where
that might have conferred a much more significant
disadvantage to us, sort of as as individuals.
If we think about the humans that have been
leaders in early clans and humans that are
leaders now, have the characteristics changed
significantly or have they sort of remained
the same from what we know?
Speaker 5: Well, it's it's a bit of a complicated
story because if you look at what we what
our ancestors were almost assuredly like for
the longest time, which is immediate return
hunter-gatherers, you eat today what you killed
today because you live pretty much on the
equator and meat rots pretty quickly. And
so everybody shares it all out in those societies.
There are no paramount leaders. There are
leaders that come and go as decisions are
being made. And so maybe you're the best hunter.
And when it's time to go on a hunt, we all
turn to you and we say, OK, David, what do
you think? Where should we go now? If you
come up with an idea we don't like, we still
don't do it, but you carry a little more weight,
you have more prestige because you're better
at it. But now it comes time to look for water
or or find a new camp, or try to decide how
to deal with those hostiles around on the
other side of the ridge. Somebody else might
step forward with the best plan. And so the
one that makes leadership effective in hunter
gatherer societies is that it's very distributed
and it's very egalitarian. We shifted away
from that when we moved to when we became
agriculturalists, because now we can store
food and create stable coalitions, et cetera.
But interestingly, the modern world is shifting
back to that. And one way to look at this
disaster in Ukraine is that you've got a paramount
leader who nobody's told no to for a very
long time. And so it's harder for him to create
and assess whether an idea is good than it
would be for somebody who's democratically
elected, who who knows that they're at the
will of the people they can come and go, and
their ideas are more important than they have
to be more persuasive.
Speaker 4: So there's this Jared Diamond has
written a little bit about, you know, when
the when the agricultural revolution happened,
you if you want to think about it very mathematically,
all of a sudden there were people who started
to be responsible for producing way more calories
than they needed. And that caloric surplus
sort of opened the door to specialization,
which includes people who raise kids and also
people who think and people who do politics
and think about law. And that type of thing
is that. Caloric surplus. The beginning of
sort of the modern idea of leadership and
politicians.
Speaker 5: Very much so. And so once we became
sedentary and we could create a caloric surplus
that we could store, you have to be like I
could create a caloric surplus in the equator
by killing a giraffe. Right. But it's going
to be gone.
Speaker 4: That's a key point. You're right.
Still being able to store it is a major thing.
Speaker 5: Yeah, exactly. So once we get to
that point where we can store it, we see society
shifts dramatically. Now, agriculture enable
that for most humans, but it wasn't always
agriculture there. For example, hunter-gatherers
in the Pacific Northwest knew where these
big salmon runs were going to come through.
And so they could create coalitions that could
defend them from other groups. They could
catch all these salmon to enough to last for
a year, almost dry them out. And now they've
got food for a very long time. So whenever
you can create or source storable sources
of energy, you've got the basis to build the
kind of society that we have whereby you can
have specialization. Everybody doesn't have
to be a hunter gatherer. People can do whatever
they want because somebody else can be responsible
for generating that caloric surplus.
Speaker 1: It's often very
Speaker 4: there's a lot of black white writing
about all of these significant leaps forward,
like the agricultural revolution, the industrial
revolution and some, some folks at least seem
driven to assign good or bad to them overall,
which which seems so fraught and difficult.
I'm wondering if there's maybe a more overarching
theme that we could identify about all of
these leaps like, for example, a lot of these
leaps bring the opportunity for a lot of good,
but also things that are not so good. So,
for example, with agriculture, we could say,
well, all of the obvious good things and specialization
and potentially reducing hunger at the same
time you started seeing, you know, animal
borne disease. To some degree, you started
seeing inequality for the first time in terms
of, hey, a lot of people can actually store
the food for the future. Is the general thing
that there's always going to be some aspects
that are problematic with any advance.
Speaker 5: Yeah, I've never seen an advance
that was an unmitigated good. There's almost
always a cost. Now, sometimes we don't envision
those costs until later. And sometimes we
don't envision the benefits till later. The
first agricultural is live, shorter lives
there, more disease ridden and they were even
they were physically shorter than their hunter
gatherer ancestors because their diet wasn't
as good. So they actually suffered a lot for
us to benefit way later. You know, we were
deal. Would you take a deal to say, well,
in a thousand generations, things are going
to be great? You'd say, Well, no, thanks.
I'll do something else. So that's one side
of the coin. I think the internet is a good
example. The other side of the coin, it's
democratized knowledge. It's made us more.
We can connect with each other more easily,
etc. But it's also done things like create
enormous amount of work as everybody in the
world sends me an email with a request for
something. It's created and used to be. They'd
have to write me a letter, and it was just
too much effort. Rice created all sorts of
polarization as people can create fake news
sites, and literally your job is to try to
make it more persuasive. So with all of these,
when we enhance our ability to communicate
with each other, when we enhance our ability
to create and store new things, we always
there's almost always something that's going
to go wrong in that context. Humans tend to
be really good at fixing those things, and
it's as a rule we'd almost never want to go
back and say, OK, well, let's get rid of the
internet. Let's start hunting gathering again.
That's right. Those things don't happen. So
we do a great job of doing our best to fix
them, but they're undeniably the problems
that accompany those changes.
Speaker 4: Yeah, one of the most interesting
books that addresses this specifically with
the internet is that I've read is Neil Postman's
book tech Napoli, where he talks about the
sort of I don't know if it's naivete, but
the idea that. Only sorting things out so
that we only get the good of any technology
or advancement is such an impossibility that
it's almost not even worth trying. It seems
better to just figure out how to deal with
and manage the bad.
Speaker 5: Yeah, I think that's a great point.
And Adam Alter is a wonderful book called
Irresistible, where he also talks about just
social media and the technology that goes
with that. And again, all that stuff is great,
but then it turns out it's highly addictive.
And so it disrupts people's lives because
they start replacing their in-person interactions
with interactions with screens. And so you've
got the approach of technology, you've got
the problems that come when you just psychologically
too attached to these things and you no longer
live the kind of life we're actually evolved
to live, etc. Every single time you've there's
pluses and minuses and you have to find a
way to navigate it.
Speaker 4: One of the points you make in your
book, if I understand it correctly, is that
following or letting our evolutionary needs
lead us leads to more happiness, all else
being equal. And I think that that's super
interesting. I'm also aware of ways in which
it's sometimes turned around and used in what
I would consider to be a negative way. Like,
for example, sometimes you will hear that
type of argument used by those against gay
marriage and gay adoption, et cetera, to say
that's not going in the direction that evolution
leads us because to men by themselves can't
create offspring. And so it's a sign that
we should be anti-gay, for example, or something
like that, which I know is not your your point.
Can you talk a little bit about what you do
mean by happier by following evolutionary
needs?
Speaker 5: Sure. So evolution pushes us to
do the things that help us survive and reproduce.
And so to the degree that we in the modern
world continue to do the things that helped
our ancestors survive and reproduce, they're
going to make us happy. And that means forming
good and long lasting relationships. That
means forming romantic sexual relationships.
They're on the gay point. You raise an interesting
one. There's actually good evidence for my
colleague Brendan Ziege that homosexuality
also evolved and that it serves purposes as
well. And so the same data applied whether
you're gay or straight, that evolution wants
you to do the kinds of things that were in
your best interest. Now the disconnects, the
problems emerge when you get to things like
this, when you get to evolutionary mismatches
between our ancestral environment and today.
And so a good example would be we evolved
to be interested in sexual variety because
it helps you sort of spread your genes into
more than one basket. You're not taking all
putting all your bet on one person. But variety
was so rare in our ancestral environment that
it wasn't that disruptive to people's long
term monogamous relationships. Whereas variety
exists every day outside my door, I can see
a new person if I live in the city. And so
it makes it really hard to stay in a long
term relationship. If you're a city dweller
in today's world, because the evolved psychology
of our ancestors, was we responding to the
fact that they probably would know a hundred
people in their entire lives? There's no way
they're encountering a million.
Speaker 4: And the reason that this was less
relevant, you say the variety was less present.
Was it just because we were in relatively
small groups that were homogenous?
Speaker 5: Yeah, yeah. We lived in groups
between 20 and 60 people. We only mixed with
people who had our same accents, Boker, same
language. If we ran into somebody who didn't
do that. We were there was a risk that they
were an enemy. We might be friendly. We might
get into a conflict. If we were friendly,
we might even use that as a chance for men
or women to switch groups to decrease inbreeding,
et cetera. But we spent our whole lives in
these small nomadic groups that didn't run
into that many different people. Mm hmm.
Speaker 4: One of the reactions that I often
see from 10, 11, 12 year olds when they, you
know, learn about evolution is it seems as
though we've stopped evolving to some degree.
And of course, you know, when we think about
modern humans, two hundred and fifty thousand
years, we sort of seemed to look the same
and so on and so forth. Can we think through
a little bit more about and this maybe this
is more of a futurism type question. What
are the evolutionary pressures now exerting
influence on humans again, now that we've
solved a lot of the things that used to kill
us very early?
Speaker 5: Yeah, that's a great question.
So if we look at our at what are called evolutionary
sweeps, which are genes that don't exist in
the past and then suddenly sweep through the
population, we can see that in fact, they've
been more frequent in the last 10000 years
than they were in the prior hundred thousand
years. So it may look like we stopped evolving.
Our bodies haven't changed much, but there've
been dramatic changes in serious ways of learning
to drink milk by producing the lactase enzyme
throughout our whole lives. Lots of things
like that. So evolution is still happening
very much at a rapid pace. But the forces
on us are now different. It used to be survival,
and now survival is kind of solved right for
most of us. We're very fortunate that that
modern medicine and agriculture have enabled
us to survive, to not have to worry about
our survival. But sexual reproduction is a
big one. Our ancestors could never disrupt
the link between sexual activity and reproduction.
And so that guaranteed they'd have lots of
kids. We can now disrupt that thing very easily,
and evolution made us want to have sex because
when we were back in the day and. That desire
was important for reproduction, we didn't
understand how to create offspring, so we've
not we don't have an evolved desire to have
kids. We have an evolved desire to have sex
and then evolve tendency to be nurturing to
those beings who come along because of our
sexual activity. Now that we can separate
out those two, I could easily imagine a world
not so far from now 30 40 generations where
there's just not that many humans because
most of us are not interested in having children.
Most of us are interested in doing other things.
Speaker 4: When we, I mean, humans, are quite
quite poor at making predictions about what
things are going to look like in the future.
Given that, what types of changes would you
be thinking about when we think about 500
years from now in terms of Homo sapiens,
Speaker 5: 500 years from now, I don't think
you'll see anything different physically.
Biologically, that's too fast. You'll see
a lot of cultural changes, and I have no idea
what those might be. You can imagine a world
with free energy and then nobody works for
a living. You can imagine lots of interesting
possibilities. But as far as us, our bodies
and stuff starting to look different or evolution
started to make us different. Even psychologically
from an evolutionary basis, you'll need at
least a minimum of a few thousand. Are you
going to start to see things in there? It's
probably going to have more to do with who
desires to reproduce and who doesn't. And
are there differences in the traits between
people who desire to reproduce and who don't?
Right now, those differences are primarily
a factor of how you live. If you're a city
dweller, you if you were kids and if you're
a rural person, if you're well-educated, you
if you were kids and if you're not. But those
are lifestyle factors that push you down a
certain pathway. What we don't know at all
is what's the psychology of somebody who likes
to have lots of kids? And what's the psychology
of somebody who doesn't? And might those psychology
then actually play an important role in our
evolution going forward?
Speaker 4: Right, right? Fascinating. The
book is The Social Leap, the new evolutionary
science of who we are, where we came from,
and what makes us happy, where we come from
and what makes us happy. We've been speaking
with the book's author, Bill von Hippel. I
can't tell you how much I appreciate your
time today. Thank you.
Speaker 5: Totally my pleasure. Great to chat
with you.
Speaker 1: Hey, this is super interesting
me. I David Pakman. I am featured in a 2022
campaign ad. This is super interesting. Now,
to be clear, I have not endorsed this candidate.
They've just used video of me talking about
stuff. It doesn't even have anything to do
with Charles Graham, but it's very interesting.
Charles Graham is running in North Carolina
and is going at David Rouser David Rouser,
who is also running in North Carolina and
has previously said how much he likes Jesse
Helms, the racist, far right senator who was
against civil rights and against gay rights
and against just about any kind of rights.
Check out the very beginning of this campaign
ad. It's very cool to see myself in it. Take
a look.
Speaker 3: Everything I know in life came
from my years with Helms, I had a great education.
Speaker 4: Jesse Helms used to be a senator
who opposed the Civil Rights Act, oppose the
Voting Rights Act, called the Civil Rights
Act dangerous.
Speaker 3: I don't think I ever learned any
more than I did when I was with Senator Helms.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So Charles Graham is currently
a member of the North Carolina House of Representatives
for the 47th District. And he's a member of
the I hope I'm pronouncing this correctly
the Lumbee tribe. And Graham is the only Native
American serving in the North Carolina General
Assembly right now. And he is running for
North Carolina's 9th Congressional District.
This is member of the House of Representatives
running against incumbent Republican Dan Bishop.
And it is a very interesting race, and I want
to talk a little more broadly about our plans
for coverage of the midterms and how people
can get involved. I'm getting more and more
live call questions and emails and tweets
and comments from folks saying I want to get
involved in 2022. What are all the best races?
I want to be involved in a ton of races. All
435 members of the House are up for reelection.
A third of the members of the Senate are up
for reelection. There's a bunch of gubernatorial
elections. I think it's really important to
set expectations and recognize you can't be
involved in every race. You can't phone bank
for every race. You can't go out and knock
doors for every race, particularly because,
you know, people generally live in one place
and you're not going to go all over the country.
So I understand the instinct to say I want
to do everything I can to try to prevent Republicans
from taking the House and or the Senate or
the governor's mansions in the state that
I live. I want to do all of it, and I get
that. But I think the risk as we spread ourselves
too thin. And so my recommendation would be
for everybody in our audience to pick one
or two races that are either local to you
or that you find to be particularly important
if you live in Florida or Arizona, but you
find Mehmet Oz to be a particularly weaponized,
dangerous candidate in Pennsylvania. Well,
get to work there. Whether it's helping John
Fetterman, who we're going to try to get on
the show or whoever else is pick that. If
your local district is a Purple District and
there's currently a Republican and maybe a
Democrat could win, or maybe there's a Democrat,
but they're at risk of losing the seat to
a Republican focus there. There's so many
interesting races it's impossible to keep
up with all of them or even to be aware of
all of the different ways that you could volunteer
your time. Narrow it down. And that would
be the approach. Now many of you have written
to me saying, David, you should really interview
this primary candidate or that primary candidate.
We can't if if we open up the door to that,
we risk every day every show being interviews
with primary candidates. And although some
of you might like it, most people expect to
get a rundown daily of what's going on, different
stories, et cetera. So we really can't do
that. And so we're going to try to pick and
choose some interesting races. My colleague
John put out a call recently on social media
saying, Who should we talk to? Many of you
want me to talk to both John Fetterman and
Mehmet Oz. We're going to try to make that
happen. Many of you have talked about House
races, Senate races. We're going to try to
pick a sort of representative sample of things
and bring it to you. Both progressives, some
incumbent centrist Democrats, Republicans.
We had wacky Republican candidate Darlene
swapper on earlier this week. So we're going
to try to do a little bit of evidence, everything
to the extent that we can, but we can't cover
every race. You can't possibly pay attention
to every race. One last thing. I know that
historically Democrats should get crushed
in November. There's no question about it.
We spoke to Rachel Beter Coffer about it and
we've talked about it six ways to Sunday.
But at the same time, things are really weird.
Everything's been weird since Trump was president,
and if you consider that more Republicans
than Democrats have died of COVID and that
a lot of the Trump people that got involved
in politics for the first time to vote for
Trump, they may not vote in the fall. And
I know it's so cliche because we always say
this, but midterms really come down to turnout.
And if some Republicans don't turn out because
they're dead and some Republicans don't turn
out because Trump's not running for anything,
it doesn't have to be a disaster for Democrats.
I'm not making a prediction. But it doesn't
have to be. And there's really a big opportunity
to do some hard work and and maybe retain
control of one or both House and or Senate.
So that's my thought right now. We have more
interviews upcoming for you. We have a voicemail
number. That number is two one nine two. David
P. The Egg Man called in and he is completely
shot out of a cannon. Listen to this. Dave,
you slayed
Speaker 2: that crazy Republican psycho lady
from Florida. But listen, when you were talking
about the death tax rate and the federal death
tax doesn't tax you, let's go over eleven
point one million. But states locally do know
they want, as she told you, that all of our
clients that say at least $250000 have to
pay a bunch of money to the state, you should
just ask. Well, then do you have a problem
with the Santas ripping off all the old people
in Florida? Gov. Rick DeSantis a steal,
Speaker 1: Ron Ron, it's not Rick, it's Ron.
But I understand pulling
Speaker 2: money from all people in Florida,
and she's taking $3000 from each and every
old person to help them hide and steal their
money from the sand. The fact that the crooked
shit.
Speaker 1: Whoa, whoa. Okay, yeah. So yes,
the Egg Man is correct, which is a lot of
these folks. So Florida actually doesn't have
a state estate tax that doesn't mean you don't
pay income tax depending on what's going on,
but that Florida doesn't have such such a
an estate tax, a state estate tax. One of
the things that should be mentioned is the
federal government gives you an eleven point
seven million dollars exemption on estate
taxes. But there are many states, including
red states, that don't that they do charge
an estate tax. And so there's a real question
there about, Listen. Biden's not taxing the
estate. If you've got five million, you don't
get hit with a federal estate tax. But in
many states, including red states, you do
get hit with a state estate tax. Why haven't
these Republican governors fix that? Why haven't
they dealt with that? Because I thought it
was the Republican governors that wanted to
take away taxes. Lower your tax burden. It's
not actually going on. You can Google state
estate tax exemptions and you'll find a lot
of information about it. We have a great bonus
show for you today on today's bonus show.
Pat is out. I will be taking the reins of
the bonus show and we are going to talk about
what on earth am I doing in Las Vegas? Who
have I been seeing here? What happened on
my flight? What's going on with COVID? Am
I getting COVID on the trip? What's happening
in Vegas? I'm going to tell you about my wacky,
delusional, outrageous Lyft driver who was
a COVID denying anti-mask. Whack job. I mean,
it's I don't even know what else to call the
guy, I'm going to tell you all about it. On
today's bonus show, sign up at Join Packman
dot com. You'll get instant access to the
bonus show. You can use the coupon code. Wow.
22 to get a discount for yourself if you're
already a member and you want to do something
nice for someone else. What's that thing from
each according to their ability? I forget
the thing. But anyway, 630 viewers have asked
for a free membership. If you want to request
a free membership, you can fill out the form
at David Pakman dot com slash free membership.
630 people are waiting for free memberships.
You can start helping us chip away at that
by checking the box that says this is a gift.
When you sign up at join Pacman dot com and
then we'll give away that gift to somebody
on that list of six hundred and thirty people
waiting. So do it. We will see you on the
bonus show and I will be back with you tomorrow,
as well as on the bonus show. Normally, Pat
does the Friday bonus show this week he did
Monday, Tuesday. I'm handling Thursday, Friday.
I'll see you then or tomorrow.